rural dar was one of the greatest
children's authors of all time
and plenty of movies have been made from
his books but wish adaptations are worth
a watch
and which he better off skipping from
worst to best these are rotten tomatoes
rankings of rural doll movies
quentin tarantino and robert rodriguez
made a roald dahl movie
which sounds like it could be either the
greatest or worst thing in the world
and well turns out it was the worst
before tarantino and rodriguez teamed up
for the anthology film grindhouse they
were two of the four directors
who participated in another anthology
film four rooms
loosely based on the adult short fiction
works of dahl
four rooms is about the myriad
adventures happening at the hollywood
hotel
with four separate segments tied
together by the bellhop played by tim
roth
while none of the director's four
individual segments are particularly
great
tarantino's is generally considered
passable though not quite enough to pass
muster with critics
four rooms received a 13 critic score
and a 69
audience score on rotten tomatoes making
it the worst movie on tarantino's and
rodriguez's filmographies
as well as dolls the witches was first
adapted to the big screen in 1990
and then again 30 years later in well
not
technically the big screen as the
witches actually debuted as an hbo max
original
set in 1967 the film finds a young
orphan boy and his grandmother
running across a convention of witches
at a seaside hotel which is led by the
world's grand high witch
who put simply isn't a very nice woman i
will reach into your
chest and rip out your withered
shriveled heart unfortunately despite a
wealth of talent in front of and behind
the camera
the witch's crash lands on his flying
broomstick as one critic put it
like far too many unnecessary remakes
the witches doesn't do enough to justify
its existence
and while the witches might have been
meant for movie theaters their results
were mediocre whatever the medium
actually make that downright rotten with
51
from critics and 42 from audiences and
rotten tomatoes
all in all it's not hard to imagine that
dah would want nothing to do with this
particular
misfire danny the champion of the world
is a less well-known role doll novel
released in 1975
it also inspired a mostly unseen tv
movie in 1989. the movie adaptation
pairs jeremy irons with his son
samuel irons who play the titular dany
together the two star is a widowed
father and son
who concoct a plan to get revenge on a
snobby property developer
dany the champion of the world isn't
exactly memorable
though it did inspire one critic to say
that it resurrects a lost world of
english life and entertainment with
winning charm and a plum
one being the operative word here
because rotten tomatoes only has a
single review for this movie on its site
as such danny the champion of the world
has no critic score
however its audience score is an
underwhelming 64
maybe if more people saw it the score
would be higher but as it stands
dany may be the champion of the world
but he's not the champion of the tomato
meter
released in 1982 royal dolls of bfg is
about a big friendly giant
the clues in the name who befriends a
precocious little girl named sophie
dole's story was first adapted to the
screen in 1989 as an animated feature
you'll be forgiven if you haven't seen
it or even heard of it though because
pretty much nobody else has
the bfg only has two critical reviews so
it doesn't even have an official tomato
meter score
though one critic praised it as a quote
giant tale of imagination with a dark
side
while another panda as quote slight and
unimpressive
so let's call it a wash the audience
scores an equally underwhelming 65
which is still fresh but nothing to
write home about more the bfg would
later go on to bigger and better things
the 1989 animated film was alas a big
freaking
dud etio trot was royal doll's last
published novel and it's just the kind
of love story you would expect doll to
write
revolving around a lonely old man named
mr hoppy a widow named mr silva
and her pet tortoise alfie seo trot was
adapted into a bbc television film in
2015 with dustin hoffman as mr hoppy
judy dench as mr silva and james corden
the rating
this charming adaptation received plenty
of critical acclaim
but it wasn't widely seen across the
pond consequently seo trot doesn't have
an official critic score on rotten
tomatoes though the one critic who
reviewed it said it was a decidedly
daffy rather ridiculously resplendent
reptilian elder romance
don't ask those who did see it quite
enjoyed it too giving the movie a
respectable audience score of 72 percent
steven spielberg decided to take on the
bfg in 2016
under the disney banner spielberg dahl
and disney
sounds like the perfect combo right
sadly the result of this historic
pairing was
just kind of okay the critical consensus
was that the bfg minimizes the darker
elements of roald dahl's classic
in favor of a resultingly good-natured
visually stunning
and largely successful family-friendly
adventure
in other words it's disney at its safest
other critics were more critical with
one writing
spielberg has become a hit-and-miss
filmmaker and this is closer to a miss
than a hit the critic's tomato score is
currently at 74
while audiences were much less impressed
giving it a 57 percent he would have
thought the combined creative might of
spielberg
dahl and disney could produce something
so darn mediocre
rouel dahl cemented his icon status by
writing children's books
but he made his living by writing just
about everything and among doll's most
interesting works is a 1965 suspense
thriller 36 hours which holds the
distinction of having been the first
ever film adaptation of his writing
set in occupy germany in 1949 james
garner plays an amnesiac american
military officer
whose last memories were general
eisenhower's final directives before the
normandy invasion five years earlier
but soon the american officer realizes a
psychiatrist you thought was trying to
help him is
actually out to get him 36 hours is
based on a 1944 doll short story called
bewear of the dog
which aptly demonstrates just how
different dao was during the war
after all the man was a spy and a
fighter pilot the results are impressive
too on both the page and the big screen
as 36 hours boasts an 80 critic score
and a 77 audience score marking the
movie is the best adaptation
of doll's adult fiction johnny depp
really could do no wrong in the
mid-2000s he had just redefined himself
from quirky in the darling actor
to quirky a-lister by starring in
pirates of the caribbean
curse of the black pearl and a year
before the sequel dead man's chest came
out
depp took a detour to dahl in 2005 he
reunited with his buddy tim burton to
play willy wonka
in arguably rower dahl's most famous
story charlie and the chocolate factory
while it may have seemed
counterintuitive at the time burton's
cinematic sensibilities toward the
creepy and the spooky
were actually the perfect fit for rua
dahl's work which always managed to
blend the surreal and scary with the
silly
and at the time you weren't going to get
a better actor to play the world famous
but notoriously reclusive chocolatier
than johnny depp
oh gosh group i lost your chocolate
i can see that said why i never expected
to have so much in common
the team had their work cut out for them
however as whatever they made would
inevitably be compared to the iconic
1971
film willy wonka and the chocolate
factory luckily burton depp and team
were up to the task as charlie and the
chocolate factory scored an 83
critic score though moviegoers didn't
find the film nearly so sweet
giving it a disappointingly rotten 51
percent
danny davidson is a genuine national
treasure but you already knew that
didn't you before he reinvented himself
as frank reynolds on his always sunny in
philadelphia
devito was actually an acclaimed actor
and filmmaker and among his most famous
films was his 1996 adaptation of rua
dal's matilda
released in 1988 matilda is arguably rua
dahl's last great work
it tells the story of a young girl named
matilda wormwood who has wicked parents
a cruel headmistress and some
extraordinary powers devito cast himself
and then wife ria pelmer as matilda's
parents while mara wilson of mrs
doubtfire and miracle on 34th street
fame earned the role of the eponymous
matilda
critics noted while the movie diverges
from rua dal
it nonetheless captures the book spirit
matilda also captured an impressive
tomato meter score too
90 from critics and 73 from movie goers
willy wonka and the chocolate factory is
arguably the most iconic ruler dull
movie adaptation
heck it's one of the most beloved family
movies of all time period and the movie
has charmed viewers of all ages since it
was released in 1971.
surprisingly however one viewer who
wasn't charmed was ruel dahl
according to a biography of the author
by his friend donald sterick
dahl didn't much care for the music or
the director and had quote
serious reservations with gene wilder's
performance as the titular willy wonka
despite that same performance having
gone down in movie history
you get nothing you lose
good day sir according to stuart
rule eventually came to tolerate the
film but he never liked it
dahl was mostly alone in his assessment
of willy wonka and the chocolate factory
however most of boasts a 90
critic score and an 87 percent moviegoer
score
it took decades for filmmakers to
realize royal dolls stories were perfect
fodder for stop-motion animation
finally however 1996 saw the release of
james and the giant peach by far one of
the best rural dial adaptations
nine years before tim burton directed
charlie in the chocolate factory
he produced james and the giant peach by
employing the same stop-motion
techniques as the iconic stop-motion
film the nightmare before christmas
helmed by nightmare director henry
selick james on the giant peach was
praised by critics with rotten tomatoes
consensus reading
the arresting and dynamic visuals
off-beat details
and light as their storytelling make
james and the giant peach solid family
entertainment
critics gave the movie an impressive 91
tomato meter score
though moviegoers were much less
impressed with their decidedly and ripe
earned a 66
score moviegoers apathy with james and
the giant peach was reflected in the
film's box office too which
bombed hard with a meager 28 million
dollars worldwide
when it comes to fantasy stories that
entertain children and adults alike
few can match the talent of rueol dal
one who certainly can however is jim
henson
creator of sesame street and the muppets
dahl's talent for storytelling and
henson's creative prowess as a producer
came together in 1990s to witches and
their results were nothing less than
magical
according to rotten tomatoes consensus
the witches is a dark and witty movie
that captures the spirit of rural dahl's
imagination
like few other adaptations critics also
praised angelica houston's quote
deliciously wicked performance as a
grand high witch
as well as jim henson's typically
brilliant puppetry all in all everybody
was on top of their game with this one
resulting in one of the most impressive
and faithful adaptations
of royal dull's work and it's got the
tomato score to prove it too
with 93 percent from critics and 70 from
audiences
fantastic mr fox of the movie truly
worthy of its name
briardale published the anthropomorphic
adventures of mr fox mrs fox and their
family and their friends in 1970
and in 2009 where's anderson adapted the
story for his first venture
into stop motion animation while
fantastic mr fox's brisk 96 pages are as
delightfully dull as it gets
the story isn't quite as best known
nonetheless the quirky whimsy of dahl's
lesser appreciated story
matches perfectly with anderson's
cinematic sensibilities
by the way you look unbelievably
beautiful tonight you're practically
glowing maybe it's the lighting while
the two acclaimed artists never met
anderson clearly shares a creative
kinship with dahl and both managed to
cultivate a similar sense of childlike
spirit in their works
and that spirit comes together perfectly
with mr fox critics seem to agree too
and with a 93 critic score and 85
percent audience score
fantastic mr fox ranks as the finest
royal dahl adaptation to date
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you